foreign
a lot of people have been sending to the
jkig they really want us to talk about
it yeah it is ruthless it's like
pretty crazy so there's this kid named
Aiden fucci right what a cool name and
food should I smelly Aiden
what is that that's ugly right in
Spanish
wait I'll smell you then Gucci yeah okay
all right yeah his name is smelly he was
uh 14 years old right and he murdered a
13 year old girl named Tristan Bailey oh
this story chapter in the woods 114 oh
my this sounds like a crime in Japan
I mean it's it's a common thing I know
you you told us stabbing chicks stupid
stabbing chicks in the forest Junior
High cycle Killers oh yeah Mountain yeah
yeah so yeah he got so he stabs or kills
her
um his his uh her body is then found his
DNA is linked to her body the police
arrest him and while he's in the
backseat of the cop car he posts
Snapchat videos like kind of taunting
the situation they let him keep this
phone captioning because he was still
like a person of interest sort of thing
I don't know 14 times not covered in
blood well they don't know yet know
right away that it's him what city is
this is weird this is like some country
bumpkin cops yeah because they didn't
cuff him yeah you can city cops are
gonna beat the [__] out of you before
they put you in the back seat it's in
Florida but yeah the um so he's in the
back seat and then he he even posted
like uh photos himself with a caption
anybody's seen Tristan lately whoa like
he's clearly
yeah and then he's um and then he pleads
guilty and he's sentenced to life in
prison at age 16 because now it's two
years later the case is now at this
point but then his mom is also charged
with tampering with evidence because
they found out she was trying to wash
the blood off his clothes oh oh wow holy
[__] love right there I I can't judge
her yeah the movie's searching with John
Chu Cho chancho right would you be able
to give up this [__] do that you
give a Bart's a [__] rat huh yeah no
Bart would 100 be washing the claws dude
they were they were just in front of the
clothes they were saying that during his
like assessment they were like this kid
has like No Remorse you know what I
would have no reason to kill her there
was no like situation it was just for
fun he just wanted to kill you know what
I would do that's so sad man so I ain't
no rat but at the same time I feel like
I would have to go to her dad and say um
I have a gift for you you want to kill
my son exactly I'd be like I'd have to
I'm like sorry you know like that's kind
of gangster but I'm like but don't you
dare go to [__] the cops you can't go
to the cops yeah we're not rats we're
not doing that [__] yeah oh that's an
interesting way to settle it but like
what would you do if you just gave birth
to a [__] demon like that bro I
turned my kid in dog
if they're a [__] demon demon if I
knew he did that and I got evidence and
I know but what if it's before let's say
you got a kid and it's before he's done
any crimes and you just know he has it
in him yeah you got to turn it into a
Dexter you can't do it for good if you
still can if if there's still a chance
or it's like hey you got desires to kill
all right yeah you gotta start with the
animals you gotta give them a hit list
of like criminals there are people in
this world that like it's okay to get
rid of right like there are
indiscriminately there's like kidnapper
Rings there's like just straight up like
jaywalker disgusting yeah jaywalkers you
don't want that Morales
yeah people who disrespected you and I'm
all like you can
get your curiosity out in the right way
people who disrespected your sports team
oh yeah people can't call your girl
people who get your Starbucks order
wrong spell your name wrong on the
Starbucks cup yeah I mean misgendering
you yeah they give you a half dome lid
when you don't need it
dude that they put whipped cream on it
forget about it bro
Dexter their asses yeah that's what I'm
saying hit him with them that is really
sad though to have her just kid get
stabbed 14 times yeah
and then the kids like mock in this
situation yeah super mocking it and just
like that's a bad egg
well yeah I mean he clearly has all the
signs of just like detached you know
he's just like like
kind of mentally he looks like a kid
who's gonna um
they showed his face you gotta say
something nice what's scary with kids
like that too though is if you're their
parents you're not immune either they'll
kill you too that's what I'm saying it's
like how can you have this kid in your
house that's a killer what about this
[__] bro that's that looks like a young
Steve Green life in prison life age 14.
all got the same haircut yeah that fool
probably stabbed her up and went to
McDonald's and got some fries and an ice
cream and dipped his fries and his ice
cream in the blood yeah that's when he
was arrested that's how you look back
then age 14. definitely looked like a
thumb with a wig a dick wig
he does a [__] thumb with them it's a
dick wig when there's no Chin involved
be careful that's what I'm really scared
of honestly it's like imagine if you
have a kid and he's just like that
Nikki's night her honest nightmare is
about that 100 we have a kid that kills
us yeah
I don't think so you got us as friends
we'll set his ass straight I agree but
usually kids like that like I'm sure he
had a single mother [__] up
environment like it's nature and nurture
right like he could be predisposed of
those things but like
come on man if Lucky watches a
documentary about something she like
thinks about it so she saw some
patricide [__] like like some 2020 [__]
brothers constantly come back that's
what it's called Patrick Yeah so it
constantly comes back to her when she
thinks about that
what's worse having a kid that wants to
kill you or having a kid that's sexually
attracted to you
they attracted to me that's easier to
deal with I could play hard to get it's
my kid a boy or girl yeah boy you can
play hard together
I could play hard to get I won't wear my
silk Jammers around them anymore I feel
like if my kid was trying to kill me I
could kill him sick I'll mark that here
you guys are sick man dude does that
happen like are kids sexually attracted
to their parents ever Freudian I guess
Oedipus Rex like stepmoms I get like
stepmoms are just hot a hot stepmom I
mean either way like the dangling broken
kid you know what's gonna come out of it
that's what I'm saying that's a broken
[__] game that's not broken that kid
is our business is though we're busted
dude it's just purely they come up to
these conclusions on their own and they
you know I there's gotta be a reason
through
upbringing too yeah I'm sure literature
pushes it over you know like I bet it's
50 50 because in most cases when you
hear these stories there's like severe
abuse happening
um I haven't heard one case or neglect
yeah I mean that's a form of abuse
though right like it's the coolest kind
yeah it's not physical abuse it's not
sexual abuse it might be cool mom
syndrome
it comes out all the time dude do you
feel like the punishment fits the crime
stabbing someone else's innocent kid 114
times to get life hell no you gotta go
firing school you should get death
you gotta rap this [__] and
[__] barbed wire and then roll them
down a hill
that's pretty creative actually it's
kind of modern cheetosis yeah this one's
got the black diamond and then by the
time it gets down
the bar went through him so he turned
into a [__] California we're all
caught up like that
so one of the reasons why people that
have uh anti-social or like uh like
these type of Psychopathic tendencies
that don't act out is when they're into
to uh person household like when their
father's around because there comes a
point when um boys can't be controlled
by their moms physically right so then
like guys having a father around scares
you just enough or gives you enough
boundaries to where like
oh [__] like I can't be wild yeah right
whereas like single that's why a lot of
boys that are in gangs that are just
like out of [__] control come from
single mother household oh yeah I mean
like look at me and Bart like like the
the level of like how much we weren't
regulated
how much we went into some Wilder [__]
and and getting into the criminal
activity yeah it's because there's no
father there beating the [__] out of you
and scaring the [__] [__] out of here my
parents mistake was my they got me into
Taekwondo because once I was like nine
years old I was overpowering my dad with
forms
they're scary forms dude
overpowered by pounding the [__] out of
them well yeah once yeah once they play
music like I just got it
my dad's in the corner like it's a jump
rope he doesn't know
[Music]
my dad disciplined me so hard I became a
dancer
[Music]
sorry dude I know I'm sorry
it sucks that sucks we can end the video
though
it's not gonna get worse than that
[Music]
foreign